so thank you for the introduction yes
like hearing I work for
um canonical and
um all the way in Australia but I'm here
for a company event anyway so I thought
I would drop by as well and as Yogi
mentioned canonical is hiring
um all over the world so you can join us
from I think we might be in 70 different
countries and people move between
countries all the time so it's a it's a
great company to come and work from
you'd be you work with some of the best
people in the world that are
having a great impact on on the
technology area
so what I'm going to talk to you about
today is about giving and receiving
great feedback through PRS this is a
somewhat I'm passionate about this topic
one of the reasons is that when I first
joined a technology company and went
through the first pull request process I
had a experience where I didn't
necessarily feel like I was sort of
encouraged and it was a good experience
to go through and part of what I'm
trying to do here is to help
improved that experience for everyone
and to help make it so that pull
requests are sort of a great asset to to
you and your team
so we'll start off talking a little bit
about what the objective of a whole
request is then we'll look a little bit
into how to
give feedback and we'll go through a few
examples and then also how to receive
feedback and then there's a checklist at
the end that is also available on my
blog which I'll have a link to at the
end that you can go to and sort of refer
back to
oh and by the way the the images are
intended to sort of convey some of the
feeling of what I'm trying to say and
there are AI generated so
um
so yeah the first topic is about the
objective of a PR and this is sometimes
where the problems can start depending
on sort of how people approach or think
about PR so one of the ways that people
think about it is that it's just sort of
the last hurdle to get to the finish
line
and you know I really want to close the
ticket I've been working on for two
weeks and you know it's Friday and I
want to feel that I've accomplished
something
and having this attitude towards pis
sort of seeing it as a hurdle can mean
that a lot of the benefits that can come
through a PR are missed
so another way to think about
what you can get out of a pull request
is
to uh
the objective is to make sure that the
code is optimal and appropriate for the
project right so it might be that a
particular contribution sort of belongs
some better somewhere else
and
some of the benefits of going through a
build request and having it well you
know well done in a team is that it's a
learning opportunity not only for to
know the person that's writing the code
is getting feedback but also for the
other people who are reading somebody
else's code and see an example of how to
implement how to solve a problem
it's also a great way to set a standard
for a project and sort of people get to
know
um you know going through the pull
request the kind of feedback that you
get and that's that is a way to
calibrate the kind of contributions that
you get as well and of course it's also
an opportunity to spot any bugs any sort
of improvements that you can make
okay so now we have a bit of an
understanding of what a healthy
objective for pull request process can
look like and then we will go through
um next we'll go through an example of
how to give feedback and some of we'll
sort of see some bad feedback and some
good feedback and we'll characterize why
some some is good and some is not so
good
okay so the first thing to think about
when you are giving feedback on a pull
request is why are you giving feedback
right and the intent sort of shines
through
the words that you write and how you say
it right and one of the important things
to keep in mind is to make sure that the
intent the true intent behind what
you're doing is to actually improve the
code and to add value to it rather than
use it as a way to block certain things
that
um or something like that
and there are a few things that are
worth it to keep in mind when you are
giving feedback to help sort of set or
calibrate how you might respond to
comments that you or what you you expect
to get out of it so one of the key
things is that the person receiving the
feedback or the comments or whatever on
a pull request doesn't necessarily have
to act on it right so it's just
it's a trigger point for conversation to
think about whether or not something
needs to change
the other thing that's important to
remember and I'm sure you have gone
through this I've gone through this
depending on how the feedback is given
can mean that it gets acted on and it's
a good experience for the people
involved or you know it can also be the
start of a bit of a comment war that
sort of thing
and the third thing which is really
important to keep in mind is that you
know we're all very passionate about
what we do the code that we write and so
on so it can be that people link the
identity to the code that they write so
when you give feedback keep in mind that
it might be perceived or people might
get defensive about it and that's an
important part of when you're framing it
is to try and minimize that perception
okay so now we'll go through an example
so the code that I've could have thrown
up any code but this is
um I write a few linters if you're
interested you can ask me about that
they're open source but this is an
example of a linter that
uh not a real linter but one that checks
whether or not
um function names are lowercase right
and what you can see there are two
problems that you can probably spot
quite quickly the first one is that on
line six the name of the function
ironically is not lowercase after linter
that's supposedly checking for that and
on line seven there's a kind of
interesting way to check whether or not
something is actually lowercase right
there's other ways in Python that are
probably easier to do okay
so let's look at line six to start with
so how might we let someone know about
our feelings of function depth so this
is kind of an example of poor feedback
right so I could say your name for visit
function death method is wrong right you
probably have never said it like that
but let's pick apart why this is a a
poor way of framing the the problem the
first thing is that you're starting with
or this is starting with your so you're
specifically addressing it at the person
who wrote the code rather than focusing
on the code itself and then it can be
very highly likely to translate to a
perception or as an attack on on the
person rather than sort of focusing on
the code
the other thing is that it's not clear
specifically what about the function
the name is wrong it's just saying that
it's wrong so it's it's not clear what
might be a Way Forward here right
okay so let's look at another way that
this feedback could be framed which is
more constructive so
what this person is saying what is the
reason for naming this method visit
function def rather than
visit functiondef and snake case and
then it goes on to say usually python
methods are named using snake case and
then there's a reference here right so
some of the key ways that this is better
is that it's addressing the code it's
not addressing the person who wrote the
code So it's talking about
why this functioning was named in a
certain way it's giving an alternative
way which the reviewer might think is an
improvement and it's also providing a
standard which you know so it's not just
an opinion it's he has an accepted
standard in the coding community of how
to name functions right so that helps to
set the help to make sure that there's
more credibility for the feedback
so I'll just give you the resolution of
this the way that the ast.node visitor
works if you're not familiar with it is
that it actually the visitor functions
have to have a visit underscope
underscore followed by the name of the
node that they're visiting and that's
why this function was named in this way
so it's actually correct so in the first
case it might take a really long time to
get to that
answer but in the second case the person
sort of or the author of the code is
likely to respond quite well to that
question and explain that you know
that's how the framework works
okay so let's look at how one more
example how we could give feedback about
the line 7 there for checking whether or
not the function name is lowercase so in
this case this person is saying would
name a node.name that is lower work in
this case which is of course an inbuilt
function so in this case you know we're
giving an example of how this could be
improved and it's still a question in
terms of whether it would be better so
it's inviting some engagement and some
further conversation
and this is also an opportunity for to
give another example so maybe this
person comes from a different
programming language where they're used
to writing this in this way
um so something to keep in mind as well
is that there's a time and place for
feedback and you know there's always an
expo request where things can be changed
or refactor small refactors and that
sort of stuff so there's a balance as to
how far you might want to push now this
is a pretty simple change so it could be
worthwhile to to sort of episode but
um you know in other examples it could
be that you pack a conversation and then
people come back to it maybe with a
fresh set of eyes a few weeks later or
something like that
okay so now we have seen a couple of
examples for how to give feedback and
certainly
um
I had this feeling when I was you know a
little bit further on in the in in my
time as a coder like is this really
necessary do we need to do this you know
I give feedback and people should read
it and you know think about whether it's
an improvement and the conclusion that
I've come to is that pragmatically if
you are careful with how you word things
and how you frame conversations it's way
more likely that you will get the
outcome or the intent that you're trying
to secret just to get to improve the
code
so it's it's over many years of
observing pull requests giving feedback
on pull requests myself and receiving
feedback on pull requests and paying
attention to how I react to how things
are framed I found that you know these
kind of techniques they help the Team
Dynamics and it also improves the
ultimate code quality outcomes
okay so we've spoken about giving
feedback there's also the other side
which is when you are the author of the
code in that case you can't control how
you will receive feedback but you can
control how you react to the feedback
so the mindset that I usually take is to
try and get as much value out of it as
possible similar to these miners who are
trying to get gold out of the ground
and how do I do that well
the first thing is how I set my mind or
how I interpret what is being said in
the comments is to assume that the other
person is trying to be helpful even if I
feel like they're not just assume it and
in actually in many cases as you start
engaging with the person asking
questions providing Alternatives and
providing reasoning then sort of the
conversation opens up and you know you
get to a good outcome
the other thing is that it's always a
good idea to respond with reasoning and
to provide reasoning before you disagree
with someone like to say okay here's why
I was sort of doing this in this way
what do you think and the other thing to
keep in mind is that blindly adopting
feedback that you receive is similar to
completely rejecting it because one of
the benefits of feedback is that you're
essentially getting a second opinion and
you can weigh and think about which one
might be accurate or get sort of
information out of it but if you just
blindly adopt what you receive as
feedback then you're just doing what the
other person would have done right so
they're essentially coding through you
and all your knowledge is sort of lost
in that case
so we've seen both sides of it in the
last time until question time I'll share
a bit of a checklist and like I said
there is I'll share my blog at the end
where you can find this checklist so it
can be a helpful reference for you and
your team to to refer to as you're going
for pull requests
okay so the first one here on the
checklist is that
um you know we naturally are inclined to
when we see something that can be
improved we're likely to sort of write
something about it it's also worthwhile
to recognize when you see something
which is a really good implementation or
a novel implementation or something that
sort of is positive about it to call it
out that also helps frame the
conversation and that it's not just sort
of you know there's lots of problems but
there's also really good things being
contributed here
the other the other thing is that it can
be that
feels some apprehension certainly in my
early days early years of a developer
I've held some apprehension about giving
feedback
and sometimes people say oh I don't have
as much experience as the other person
or you know
there's something else that's going on
it's worthwhile to overcome that and
you're not always going to be right when
you give feedback it'll be a good
learning opportunity regardless and
something to consider as well though is
it can be reasonable not to give certain
pieces of feedback because maybe the
time is wrong or maybe you know there's
a something else that's going on like we
really have to get this release done or
something like that and it's worthwhile
not to implement certain things
the other thing which I shared a little
bit earlier but I'll just reinforce it's
important not to use sort of you your
eyes or that because that can drive the
conversation towards the people involved
rather than the code and then you get
into all the problems of identity and
people wanting to make sure to defend
their name and that sort of stuff so
it's always good to focus on the code
and address the code rather than address
the people involved
the other thing that's web file is to
use words that sort of signal that you
have a
um like that you're still open to change
your mind or that you might not have all
the information so things like scenes or
could are good words to use especially
if you're not 100 sure about certain
things
as the conversation goes on sometimes I
become more assertive when you know when
it's obvious what the appropriate
approach is but certainly early on it's
good to use sort of this seems to be
there seems to be an opportunities for
improvement here what do you think those
sorts of things
the other thing that's where file is to
prompt other people for their opinion
when you've given your opinion because
it shows that you're interested in what
the other person has to say and then
they are more likely to be interested to
sort of read what you've written and be
interested in what what you have to say
foreign
the next Point here is to if there is
some sort of focus on the people
involved it's always good to redirect to
the code and avoid sort of retaliation
you know it's worthwhile if if that's
happening in your team to maybe approach
your leadership and try and improve the
situation
um in the moment it can be helpful to
just focus on the code and on on the
outcome that you're trying to achieve
um when you sort of give or you disagree
with something it's always good to start
with the reason if you start with I
disagree with you and here's the reason
then the other person is sort of to get
to or inclined to also disagree with you
and if you start with a reason then the
other person is probably going to read
the reason and then you can discuss that
reason rather than just keep disagreeing
with each other
it's important to read and listen to
what is actually being said I've seen
many cases where people are just
disagreeing with each other but they
haven't realized so that violent
disagreement is not as in physically but
as in like people are very sort of
arguing but they're not arguing in
reality so it's always important to kind
of keep listening to what the other
person has to say and also make sure
that you're discussing the same topic or
you're not sort of talking past each
other
um yep the other thing that's always
regardless of how senior UI always keep
in mind that you might be wrong as well
so it's a very healthy thing because
you know sometimes you think somebody
else is wrong well flip side is that you
and I are sometimes wrong as well
um sometimes it's worthwhile to accept
progress over Perfection
um
that way at least you make some progress
and then you can keep making progress
and iterate towards having really good
contributions
the other thing that I sometimes see is
that people want to land their change so
they accept the feedback and implement
it even if they disagree with the
feedback so it's important to sort of
talk that out and figure out what the
optimal approach is rather than
um just make the change so that you can
then the
pull requests and the other thing that
is important is that
you shouldn't feel like implementing
feedback is important to maintain a
relationship this should be independent
you should have a good working
relationship anyway and
um then resolve the you know the
technical issues sort of the real issues
with the code and use that healthy
relationship if somebody makes it sort
of a condition that you implement the
feedback on that you have maintained a
good relationship that's kind of
unhealthy and it's worthwhile to try and
address that especially with the
leadership
okay so the last four items and then we
can go to some questions
share that before it's always good to
assume helpful intent even if
you know that you're certain that there
isn't that can be a great way to turn
around turn the situation around and
actually get to the point where
um it's everyone involved has helpful
intent
I shared before that you know I actively
observe how I'm responding to what I'm
reading so this is a really good skill
to develop and not just sort of directly
engage in the emotion like if you feel
or this person is attacking me then if
you still have a choice about what you
do about it you don't have to sort of go
to your first instinct and and go for it
this lesson took me a few years to learn
sometimes when someone disagrees with
you
keep talking and you try and convince
them and then the viewpoints get more
and more entrenched one of the things
that helps is to give people time to
sort of process what is being said and
to for them to think about it and then
the really good people to work with they
actually sort of Advance the thinking in
the background and when you come back to
it a few hours later a few days later
you might be very might be surprised by
how much progress both of you have made
if you give each other time and that
includes yourself sometimes in the
moment you disagree and then you think
okay maybe maybe I was wrong as well and
I can advance my thinking in a certain
way
and the last Point here is that when you
receive feedback it's important not to
just focus specifically on the feedback
that you receive but also sort of think
about okay you know I got some feedback
on the naming of this argument but maybe
there's some broad issue that was some
broad improvements that we can make put
to the design or something like that
okay that's all I wanted to share so
that's the jdk anderson.com is my blog
so if you go there
um you can there's a link for the python
posts that I've written and one of them
is titled the same as this talk so even
if you go there at the bottom I have all
of the the checklists that I shared
before if you'd like to email me that's
my sort of
professional email and then also my
canonical email address especially if
you're interested in joining the team
and I'm also on fostered on as well
So yeah thank you and I think we have a
bit of time for questions now
so it's just working oh yeah and so you
got like many many questions I think it
was 25 by now so we won't be able to go
through all of them but I will start
like with the most like highly aborted
ones so um the first one it's like um
how do you deal with PRS that are well
intended but so bad that you don't know
where to begin with the review
so there are
there are a few things that I can say
about that so one of the great things
that we have in our team is that we are
really good at writing down what we
expect of each other so we have a
contributing guide which you know I get
sometimes we get feedback it's a little
bit long so if you have that in your
team
then people can look at what you expect
from the contributions and rather than
sort of you having to explain it over
and over
people can read it and sort of
understand what's expected the other
thing which can help a lot and we make
use of this
um in our team as well is that we have
automated checks so one example is we
have a some guidelines about how to sort
of put together a doc string in Python
and then we have some tooling that
checks that it's accurate it's actually
open source and you can find it on my
blog as well
um
and then so and that tool actually
guides people to how to fix the problem
so those are some really good things the
other thing that is quite helpful is
yeah if you have a sort of newer person
to the team
or uh
you know someone with a little bit less
experiences and again this is something
that we're doing at canonical as well in
our team is that we encourage people to
write specs or designs before they start
implementing something and then that is
a really good opportunity to give some
early feedback so you can sort of
intervene a little bit early
and then the other thing that you can do
if if it's sort of too late for that is
that you can sit down and pay a program
with someone and you know try and have a
mindset of you know there's good
intentions here let's try and help this
person actually achieve the outcome
right and that can be a really good
learning opportunity for both both
parties involved
okay um the next question is um how do
you encourage a practice of thorough
PR's reviews when people just go looks
good to me and approve all the time
yes this is something so one of the ways
that you can do that is by setting an
example so
I always take quite a bit of time to
review pull requests and you know I get
a lot of thank yous for that as well
when you people can tell that you've
thought about it and then the other
thing that I find is that that gets
reciprocated so all the PRS that I
submit even some of them are very long
and sometimes and you know I get
feedback about that too
um
I still get really good feedback and
good engagement from people so it's in
in the moment it's difficult to develop
but it's something that you can train in
a team and sort of champion as well
the next question is
um oh now it's changed
um in open source it seems that PR's
using explicitly polite language are
frowned upon
um affront upon whether straight to the
point feedback so Where's the Line to
hostility
so
you can be straight to the point and
avoid some of the pitfalls as well right
so all the examples that I discussed I
don't think they multiplied the content
in a big way the you know the examples
that we looked at they were still
straight to the point it was just framed
in a way that
encourages more conversation and more
interaction with people or some more
thoughts rather than outright rejection
and you know that for the other person
it doesn't feel very good so those are
some of the things to keep in mind is
that you don't have to
um you know it doesn't mean that you
have to Waffle around a lot and talk
beat around the you can still
be to the point and still be sort of
respectful and thinking about how the
other person might react
um
in form of questions actually best
practice doesn't it always almost always
implicitly conveys sarcasm
um
I don't think so I think it depends on
how you frame the question and it
doesn't always have to be a question
it's that's one of the tools that you
can use to encourage further
conversation if it's warranted in some
cases it might not be warranted and the
other thing to keep in mind is that it's
uh if you're going through a
conversation
um you know at the start of it
especially a complex conversation you
kind of have to broaden the conversation
a little bit and feel each other out and
have that doing that through a question
is a really good way of doing that in
other cases where you know there's a
very clear standard that you've set and
I do this all the time as well is that I
say hey we have to stand it should be
applied here and then that's a fairly
straightforward and you know people can
go look at the standard and see if it
applies or not so
you can frame feedback as questions and
have it be sarcastic
um certainly possible and but I think
it's also possible to frame questions to
frame feedback as questions without them
being sarcastic
and when giving a feedback with a link
to the documentation don't you fear it
could be interpreted as read the
manual
um
I think that's that's the in the eye of
the beholder it's worth well especially
if someone is new they might not have
read through every single
um every single sort of point in the
documentation and it's worthwhile to
give them some um some details about it
and the other thing that I tend to do is
that I you know I write a few blog posts
about topics that I keep giving feedback
about and sometimes I point people at
that as well so if you have a a
well-documented and well-written source
which addresses
um the the issue at hand it's much
better to just refer to that and have
people read that than use sort of
manually rewriting it over and over and
over I mean the other thing you can do
is you can copy from the documentation
if if you really want to avoid that
perception but
um
I think that
if the way that you go through and give
feedback and engage with people will
shine through and I certainly have never
had feedback
like that like that Sarah you're just
telling me to read your documentation
kind of give me the answer I think
people appreciate those things in many
cases
so I would love to read all the like the
next 15 questions but uh um I think
here's the last one
um do you have any ideas on how to how
to incentivize your co-workers to give
feedback
um yes so this is a
uh
sometimes co-workers don't give as much
feedback as you'd like them to and one
of the things that you can do that is
after somebody has given you feedback
you can thank them for it which
encourages more more feedback in the
future the other thing that we do is you
know we have our leadership make sure
that we recognize people that give
really good feedback so there are things
that you can do in the team to sort of
make it culturally more likely that
people will give feedback and depending
on how people generally feel about the
way that pull requests happen in your
team will also influence whether or not
they tend to engage with with the
process more or less
okay thank you
[Applause]